[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys
anna welcome back to the layout higher
pen show
powered by icon plus so a really quick
news announcement for you
so while the largest banks and companies
in korea are accelerating the adoption
of icons did service
icon is also launching three d5 projects
in q1 or 2021
so decentralized identifiers could take
deep by mainstream as it's secure
easier for institutions to on board so
great news always coming out of of icon
desk so
i also want to say thank you to my
sponsors block buy so i actually use
them to earn up to 8.6
interest on my usdc so uscc is a stable
coin which is pegged to the us dollar
and so i'm going to leave a link in the
description a link in the comments a
link everywhere so if you guys want to
sign up for them you can
um you can actually get up to 250 at the
moment and depending on how much money
you deposit with them so i think that's
great
and before we bring on my um very
exciting guests
i want to just give a huge shout out to
coinflip so they're doing some
incredible work across the states to
push bitcoin mass adoption
um they now have 1 200 bitcoin atms
which is really cool across the state so
giving everybody access to bitcoin so i
also have a discount code for them
you can get 10 off your transactions i
think that's great so i will
leave that um i'll leave that in the
comments below so
i'm going to introduce a guest today um
he comes from the traditional world of
finance
caused a little bit of a start online
recently um on crypto twitter
he is a former goldman sachs executive
and now actually has 98
of his portfolio um in crypto so that is
insane it is the man that's based in the
cayman islands
it is raul powell how are you doing i'm
great how are you
i'm good i'm good it's hard to get all
that out you know
but i'm glad to bring you in how is it
in the cayman islands how are you doing
it's great it's actually freezing cold
right now it got down to
about 24 degrees which for us is like
the depths of winter
but hopefully it'll go back
24 degrees that that's bad that's
amazing you're talking like actual
degrees like we do in the uk
yeah celsius so that's freezing for us
i'm wearing jeans today that's not
normal
oh my god you're living the dream out
there well i'm back here in the uk
and it is absolutely freezing um
so yeah i want to talk about your
journey into the cayman islands because
you're one of the biggest names in
finance you know from
not west to goldman sachs to real vision
and it all started at plymouth
university so i want to go back and i
want to understand
how you got to where you are today and
what are some of the biggest
challenges that you faced and how did
you overcome them
well the story is is i took
my um for english people don't know what
this means they're a levels
that's the exam make it about 18 years
old i had discovered
cars pubs and girls so i failed all of
my exams
and i had to be i had to go and retake
them at a cramer in london
in notting hill i then cobbled together
enough a levels to get one university
offer which was plymouth
yeah the only place i could get into so
i got
i went to plymouth i came out with a
decent degree in economics and law from
plymouth
and graduated in a recession and
i wanted to go either into financial
marketing
my dad was from a marketing background
and i was quite interested in that
um but finance you know it had been the
end of the 80s and it had been
kind of everybody driving porsches and
it was all very exciting
so i thought that's what i wanted to do
so i spoke to a friend of my dad's
uh at his birthday party once and said
you know what should i do i'm thinking
about marketing or finance he said well
it's really easy to think about
because you can go and work for a
company like mars fantastic marketing
and i will give you free mars bars or
you can go and work for a bank and get
free money
i was like okay that's what i want to do
problem was i went to a bad university
we're not great university
and a recession and there were no jobs
so
that made me think okay how do i how do
i get to where i'm going and that
started my journey of living in the
future where i stopped thinking okay
that's where i want to be how do i get
there and actually what i wanted to do
was work for goldman sachs but they were
never gonna take me i already had a draw
full of
200 rejection letters from everybody and
so i had to figure out okay how is it
going to do it
and i became a i managed to get on the
graduate training program
for a company called dow jones tellerate
which is like bloomberg it was like
it was the number two in the marketplace
at the time and i managed to get in that
and then eventually talked my way into
a trading desk where i was doing equity
derivative sales
and i was doing that for six months
started doing quite well at it as a
salesman
and then my boss left and i was made
head of the desk
wow that's convenient that's a big
opportunity
and that's what kind of launched my
career that's insane i think
like you kind of have the playoff here
between
luck is in like good timing um but then
also
preparation from yourself right because
like you said you got you had all these
rejection letters but you were still
sort of like
no i'm gonna push through so between if
you had to weigh up luck
versus preparation you know which would
you say
was k more into play here actually you
know it was very difficult to get luck
when
you graduated into a recession so so
that was
that was more cunning than luck and then
luck
played you know luck plays a huge part
but it's leveraging luck that plays the
biggest part
so once you see the opportunity then you
can start to really leverage it
yeah i hear you but there's this idea
right that
in life we've got to get a good stable
job we've got to work that nine to five
and once you work that nine to five then
you're on the right path you're doing
the great thing
um but slowly people sort of waking up
and saying this isn't quite
you know the case so what is your
journey in that respect because
obviously you know
you were at goldman sachs now you're
sort of off in the cayman islands you
know you've got real vision and all this
stuff so
what's your opinion on that my opinion
is and it's probably changing over time
but having something really good on your
cv
having been exposed to people who are a
lot smarter than you
have a lot more knowledge than you is
invaluable
because it gives you a credibility
statement so nothing up until me working
for
goldman really mattered because nobody
cares about natwest as a uk bank yes
we were doing some cool stuff at the
time we were the leaders in the uk
and in probably in europe at the time
but then i got poached to go to goldman
and that was the biggest opportunity of
my life it's like can you set up hedge
fund sales here
and that's what i did i was kind of well
known for it in the industry
but with goldman it was like well this
is easy i can call up anybody and say
hey i'm from goldman sachs setting up
patreon sales can we talk
so it was very easy to do um
and develop it from doing that but that
move to goldman meant that
everywhere i went i've been vetted
so everybody says like you did oh ex
goldman sachs
yeah whatever reason it's actually
really to do with the quality of people
you're surrounded with it gives you a
network
and you know yes to be an entrepreneur
from scratch is a great thing too
but anywhere you can build a network and
and
get knowledge um actually
supercharges everything in the end so
it's a combination of the two be the
entrepreneur
but also if you can get that meaningful
network from working at an amazing firm
so a lot of people will go to google now
you know i worked at goldman it was this
number one requested place to work by
mbas around the world so
you know i would not have ordinarily got
in that i i got into it because i'd
proven myself beforehand
but anybody else if you work for an
amazing tech firm let's say
um and then want to branch out people
always say
oh he learned at google or stuff like
that and you've been vetted so
that's that's the tip if you can ever
orchestrate that that's the best of
everything
yeah i think i can i can relate because
i i worked for many different
news stations before i sort of jumped
full-time into crypto
um and you know when you're working for
the smaller news stations and you're
trying to get people on as a guest
they don't really know your station they
don't really care you know especially
like the little london ones
and you know when you're when i've done
some work at the bbc so when i say oh
yeah i'm calling from the bbc
they're coming on there's no and then
you can also say
oh well i used to work for the bbc and
now i'm doing that
right credibility statement and then
okay here we are now
yeah exactly so speaking of here we are
now you are notorious for holding um the
majority of your portfolio in crypto so
that's insane but before we get into
that i want to know
why bitcoin and when did you first come
across it i'm talking i wanna heal
hear that red pill orange pill moment
so i was living in spain writing my kind
of institutional research product global
macro investor
over the financial crisis and the
european crisis in 2012 when europe
almost
fell apart when the banking in spain
where i was living
almost completely broke down and so i've
been watching all of this and we've been
seeing
the growth of debt and a lot of
structural problems within the finance
industry like who owns what
when lehman brothers lost so i realized
there was problems
and then the solution starts to become
printing of money
and so it got many of us down the path
of okay what does this all mean
and gold becomes one of those things at
the time i was more worried about the
financial system
itself so i was going around with a
bunch of kind of
well-known hedge fund people uh looking
at setting up the world's safest bank
uh and we this was going to be a
non-fractional reserve place of for
people to store assets and have services
and it's hard to set up a bank so we
kind of gave up eventually
and i had a round table for global macro
investor members
in spain and i was talking about some of
these journeys that i was on
and a guy presented to us all on bitcoin
he's another ex-goldman sachs guy a guy
called the mill woods
who's gone on to do a lot of amazing
things in the industry
um and emil is very below the radar
screen so i probably hate the fact that
i mentioned his name
and so um what happened was
he presented bitcoin as the answer
and i'd seen the rise from about 2011
and had been following it a bit i
started writing articles about it and
invested
first time in it and maybe 2012.
i think 2012 i first started investing
in bitcoin
so i bought it 100 in a month and i sold
it i was like okay that was quite
interesting
uh and then i kind of followed it for a
bit
and started getting people more
interested in it and then i kind of
reinvested again probably in 2014
and sold out into the big rally in 2017
as i got confused about forks and you
know what does this all mean
i don't really know so i'm gonna get out
um
and so so that was that i then started
to learn about
blockchain technology again from emil
and a few of the others at the round
table coming out of that round table is
why people
like dan tapierra and mark yusko are all
because they're all global macro
investor guys
that's why they all got into bitcoin
it's because they all heard about at the
same time we're all like okay
then we started hearing about blockchain
technology that got us
all start thinking about the digital
asset space overall
and where this is all going again this
was super early kind of 2015
we started learning about that whole
space um
and so from that i then got back in
again because
i'd sold out i wasn't back in again the
price had been falling
and then dan tapiero started annoying me
almost every day
by saying we need to talk about bitcoin
i'm like i'm not interested right now
there's a lot going on with a dollar a
lot going on with bonds he goes no we
need to talk about this
and so eventually we did a piece on real
vision and
um and then dan got me back into
bitcoin again which was 2018 and i
started investing again and spending a
lot of time in the space
so speaking of dan and bitcoin and stuff
i
watched a video um on i think i think it
was real vision at the beginning of this
year
um before well actually not before
actually in march as soon as
everything just kicked off right you
mentioned printing of money
everything shut down so i want to talk
about quantitative easing because
i find that it's such a such a like a
controversial kind of topic you know
people
you know central bank sort of do it to
stimulate the economy and everything's
all very exciting and you know
joe biden's proposing another 7 trillion
it's all very great but you know
people like in this space people like
you you know we're all quite concerned
about this we don't necessarily think
it's great so
talk to me about quantitative easing um
especially
how you know what we what's what we saw
happen in march and
how the year has kind of like looked
since then yeah
quantitative easing means different
things to different people in terms of
in terms of its effects yeah everybody
in the stock market thinks quantitative
easing is what
drives the stock market higher the
central bankers thinks it's what
stimulates the economy the europeans
probably thinks
it's what holds together their economy
because if not all the banks go bankrupt
and the crypto space in the gold space
thinks it debases currencies
right so we've all got a different
narrative based around this
the narrative that i've found is most
consistent
is the debasing of fiat currency over
time and i started looking at this in a
different way i came at it with gold
so i thought okay if gold is money let's
take that as a hypothesis
then gold should establish a price
versus other things over time so i chart
gold versus
real estate gold versus equity markets
copper gold versus things right real
assets
and you can go back 100 years 200 years
and most of the time
it trades here in the range so it's
consistent in saying
it prices money you know the value of
goods and they
they vary around that so then i started
putting gold
versus a basket of 27 global currencies
because i saw everybody's printing
so let's see not gold in dollar terms
but against this basket
and lo and behold the picture comes
clear that as they print
gold rises versus these currencies they
stop printing it flattens out
they start printing it rises i'm like
huh
fascinating so it's showing you that
even though the printing of money
doesn't necessarily generate
inflation i the cost of your tvs
you know in the supermarket don't go up
but the value of your money
falls in this kind of weird world of
foreign exchange markets
and if they're all doing it you don't
see it because it's not like your
currency's falling it's not venezuela
what you're finding is all of them are
lowering in value versus hard assets
which is one of the reasons the art
market's gone up and the collector's
cars market's gone up
and gold's gone up and bitcoin's gone up
so it's that
whole concept of easing so then when we
saw this happen in march
we realized that with this much debt and
this bigger economic shock
it was going to be massive and it was
going to be quick as well because it's
the only trick
the central bankers knew because
interest rates were zero
so then they also explained that
because velocity of money is low because
most of the banking systems around the
world aren't operating properly
the only way to get money in people's
hands was give it to them directly
but the governments couldn't afford to
do that so the central bank were
essentially going to pay for it by the
back door
and once you started doing the joining
the dots and looking forward
i realized okay this was going to be a
really unique moment in time for bitcoin
because it was going to be a key driver
i'd also followed previous recessions
and the quantitative easing or the
stimulus tends to go on
18 months two years maybe three years
afterwards
so this was only the start um
and so that's why i got very aggressive
very quickly in the space
so what does that mean for the dollar
then right because the dollar is
supposed to be
um you know this global currency people
sort of run to the dollar you know
even i know i know venezuelans are
obviously buying crypto but they're also
buying the dollar
um you know all over um these kind of
countries you have kiosks where people
can literally
change their money into dollars so what
do you think about the dollar i mean
it's down do you think people say you
know it could potentially become the end
of its lifespan
do you think it's still um i guess you
know i mean i know sort of talk about
gold is that safe haven asset but
the dollar do you think that has much of
a lifespan do you think it could be
replaced
uh no i don't think it's gonna replace
fully
um right now eighty percent of the
world's transactions are done in dollars
while the us is 25 percent of world gdp
so it's actually it has an outsized
impact on the globe
that's one of the reasons all of these
other central banks are trying to move
to central bank digital currencies and
talk about
trying to reduce the dollar's weight in
the world that will happen
will it happen yet is the dot has the
dollar rolled over properly yet
or is this the bottom end of a range i'm
not entirely convinced that it's rolled
over yet
i still think the dollar may go higher i
could be wrong i've been wrong this year
on it
um if it continues to go lower
well we've got this narrative of what
the imf and the
bank of international settlements and
everybody else is talking about which is
either fragmenting into basket
currencies using central bank digital
currencies
or doing something that reduces the
dollar's weight in world trade
which everybody desperately needs if
that's the case
then the number of dollars held by
people will fall and the dollar will
fall itself
so again there's there's a whole other
narrative in the background that is very
very positive
for crypto i do not think the dollar is
at risk of hyperinflation
uh loss of reserve status or any of that
that's just
narratives of people wishing that their
assets assets go up faster it's not the
way the world works
yeah i think it's pretty interesting um
you know especially in the crypto space
there's this huge narrative
of um you know inflation and we're not
seeing hyperinflation it's not
it's not what we're seeing um no and
we're
very very very unlikely to see it
because of this aging demographic this
massive population
the fact that the banking system doesn't
work fully to create hyperinflation is
actually really really difficult to do
so you know it's not even clear we can
generate inflation don't forget the
japanese have been printing money
for 20 odd years now they have been
fiscally stimulating for 30 years
they're buying their own stock market
they're doing everything and they still
don't generate inflation
because of demographics and demographics
is the key driver of everything
so no i don't believe in any of those
narratives could that happen in
30 years time 40 years time maybe
still doubt it okay that's pretty yeah i
think it's pretty interesting but you
know when we look at um
these safe haven assets there's this
huge um
you know tug of war between gold and
bitcoin um especially
um you know i guess in your community as
well i mean i know you mentioned dan
tepiero there
so what are your thoughts do you think
you know they could work simultaneously
as the safe haven assets gold and
bitcoin
could bitcoin potentially you know
surpass gold i mean i know mark josco
has sort of made comments on that it
could if it reaches a certain market cap
um they exist together
they do similar things one is for the
modern age which is bitcoin
actually integrates perfectly with the
new digital system
um and so it makes much more sense
it also is generational sure gold's been
around for five thousand years
is not going away it will always be a
store of value but
you know if you're younger you probably
have a propensity to understand the
value of a digital asset better than
um somebody who wasn't brought up with
digital assets
so i think there's a generational shift
so i do think over time because bitcoin
is not only this kind of reserve asset
store of value pristine collateral which
is what gold is
it also as a technology and it has that
whole technology layer that offers
a different potential future so i think
over time the combination of those the
knockout punch which means
it outperforms over time which is one of
the reasons i sold all my gold
i've seen you know bitcoin is basically
outperforming every other asset on earth
and we haven't even started the peak
point of the
halving cycle pattern so you know the
chances the point of owning any other
asset right now is
is almost zero um so gold will probably
underperform
but gold probably goes up too so what is
it about bitcoin though because
so how much of your portfolio is
actually in bitcoin i i mean i read
recently that it was 98
but i don't know if that's just like
crypto in general yeah no 98
is crypto in general of which it's an 80
80 20 split between bitcoin and ethereum
good choices good choices so why bitcoin
what are like the top five things
you have to do i'm not gonna tell
anybody anything that they don't know
although i think i was the guy who came
up with the pristine collateral
idea is what i like about it is
obviously the res the the
restricted supply there's nothing like
it you know the distributed nature of it
um the divisibility exchangeability
um you know the digital asset the way it
can be moved around the world is
is phenomenally powerful um
and the immutability of the whole thing
and the blockchain technology so all of
that is great everyone knows that
at application level i think it's it's
very interesting just as a replacement
to gold
you know it works you can store it
offline much you can do with gold and a
gold vault
but it's it's easier to transport and
there's a number of other benefits
i think um so the store of value thing
is pretty obvious the collateral thing
is a very different thing
that people haven't got their heads
around so the world runs on
collateral so collateral is what allows
you to borrow money
the whole world runs on one
true source of collateral which is us
government bonds european government
japanese government bonds they also are
but u.s government bonds are
the the most prestigious collateral of
all problem is
is that collateral they can issue more
of it
at any one stage and
in a recession when the value of the
collateral so if you want to borrow
money for me it's a bad recession you
can't get money
and you want some of this collateral so
you can borrow money you should pay me
more money for it
the current system is the opposite
because the central bank lowers interest
rates
and the price and collateral actually
gets cheaper so i'm taking risk and
lending it to you but i'm not getting
paid the reward bitcoin changes that
dynamic because i'd be able to charge
a different rate for lending you my
pristine collateral
because you can't mess around with it
it's distributed there can be no more
supply
it's got recorded ownership there's a
whole bunch of things
that doesn't happen with the treasury
bond market so you know i i think that's
one of the key things for me that i
think okay
i can see something massive that this
could be the base layer of an entire
financial system
so then with all of that in mind where
do you say the base layer of an entire
financial system like that's a huge
statement you know because
there are people out there whenever i
post about bitcoin i mean you know
people were
screaming scam this that and you know
all these things and obviously
to say these kind of things they
obviously don't understand it but you
know it's difficult well it's not
necessarily difficult to use but
grandma can't use it yet you know that's
sort of like what we say
this is why it's priced as its price
right this is why it comes up
like metcalfe's law which is the
adoption effect right
so it's still being adopted so we've got
to that yet you know my job
as a macro guys to live in the future as
i talked about before
so we're looking at possible futures and
that seems like a pretty high
probability
future potential and it's the path of
getting here to there is where you make
all the money
it's not there because when it's there
it's a low volatile
risk-free asset i want to take it when
it's risky and nobody believes it
because that's when you make all the
money when everybody adopts it that
brings all the money into the space
yeah i'm totally with you but i'm okay
so you're living in the future tell me
how do you see this asset though do you
see it as a store of value do you see it
replacing the dollar i know you said
not quite do you see it as a global
currency do you see it's a global
reserve currency like
what is bitcoin's place what could its
place be that's bit we don't know
could it be the pristine collateral
that the world uses to offer leverage on
yes
that's certainly quite possible is it
likely to be the payments layer
don't know but could it be you know
we're seeing bitcoin wrapped on ethereum
there's no reason it has to be the
platform it can be the asset
so will we see other central banks or
central banks put it onto their balance
sheets
for sure because if it goes up a lot and
it's hard money
and you're a latin american country
that's had problems with devaluations
and all of this
well game theory would suggest that
somebody's going to try it soon
and it's going to make their currency go
up and it's going to help them and in
which
case it encourages others to do it so i
do see adoption
by central banks um i do see
a dual world where fiat currency and
bitcoin exist
and one is an on-ramp and off-ramp so
you happen to live in a country and you
live in that country you have to pay
your taxes in that country
but you want to store your money in the
universal currency i think that's pretty
true too
so could bitcoin be everything
there's definitely a probability of that
how high that probability is
i don't know because we're looking 20 or
30 years out at that point
so it's too difficult to assess but i do
know we're going to move towards that
and again in investment terms that
moving towards it the rate of change
is rule where all the part where it gets
very interesting
so you got yourself into a bit of um
stir
online i'm talking regulation
talking xrp we'll get to xrp in a bit um
but with regards to regulations so you
said that
um regulation will come and you will
still
use the crypto essentially um which is
pretty interesting because actually
today i read a news article that um
france have now um brought in a
potential new kind of regulation which
would actually
stop french people from using any
anonymous crypto accounts so
given the nature of crypto that's that's
quite huge um for regulation so
how do you see do you see regulation as
this necessary evil in terms of
mass adoption or do you are you do you
support regulation what are your
thoughts
the world is always about trade-offs and
something like bitcoin doesn't care what
you think it should be
it will be what it is right it's a
distributed system
that has a life of its own so it will go
wherever it goes
depending on the demand and use cases
so if people want it to go up in price
then more people need to buy it it's the
very nature of the asset
if more people need to buy it then
the reality is it won't be driven by
retail investors
it'll have to be driven by institutions
those institutions
cannot buy it without more regulation or
enough regulation
so if not their trustees won't allow
them to buy it and
it's dead so in which case it remains is
what it is dead as a
as a institutional asset so in which
case it's a retail asset
that's okay too it's just a different
future
but if you want to have a hyper bitcoin
coinalized world the traditional
financial system
has to use it and that's going to take
regulation
i am prepared to take the trade-off of
privacy because i don't think we have
any you know we're currently on a google
chrome browser they know exactly where
you are
that you're talking to me where i am
they know my email address they know
everything about it they know what
websites i've just visited
they know every single aspect they know
you know
we are tracked by everything and
everybody
so i'm not that fast and blockchain
tracks all of the movements of the money
anyway
so my anonymity if it's to avoid paying
taxes
well you can play that game and maybe
you get caught maybe you don't
that's up to you but i also know if i
live in a country
where taxes are due for services i'm
happy to pay them other people aren't i
get that
um but unfortunately that's why you've
got a passport that's what it tells you
is
we will protect you we will give you
services you may not think you get the
value for money
but if you want to live here you have to
pay taxes that's what it is what people
want it to be is a different matter so i
don't see
a problem with it i don't see a problem
with regulation
i've worked in financial services my
whole life uh regulation is just part of
what it is
i also know that this is an incredibly
smart community of developers and
if they try and stop some form of
custody wallets
that can't be uh anonymous
somebody will figure another way out
because nature
it's almost impossible to fight that
battle
so what we will find is the main players
in the space
will be regulated both the investors and
the service providers
and a ton of smaller service providers
that offer different solutions that will
be
not regulated because they will find
jurisdictional ability or other ways
of doing it so i don't worry about it
whatsoever
i think the market might even sell off
on it because there's a panic
and i think that's going to be a huge
buying opportunity because
two things happen one adoption is good
secondly people will solve the problem
for individuals who
who want anonymity yeah but i i think
what kind of gets me is
that you know solving the problem of
anonymity i think that that anonymity
given the news about france is going to
be taken away i just don't think we can
have that kind of
anonymity you don't have any anonymity
now
you have a bank account you have a
credit card the amount of cash
transactions is limited in europe
you're only going to take out a certain
amount of cash um
so there is i mean anybody who thinks
there's this
free world of money is it's nonsense
nobody can but that's the goal though
isn't it but that's the goal and
so don't find what
right the goal of bitcoin there is no
goal it's distributed it goes wherever
it goes it's a network
it's not a person it's not a philosophy
it's none of those things
and everyone hates that but i said look
you can have your own view on it and if
you can corral enough people
to do the same thing as you but bitcoin
is not that it's a living
breathing network yeah it's pretty
interesting isn't it because the
community is so
tight right and there's narratives
and there's ideas and the propaganda is
wild like it's like
state-of-the-art propaganda like and so
i think
like i think it's really interesting to
hear somebody actually say well actually
you know who says that's the goal we
don't even know the person that created
it
so how do we and they're not in charge
of it nobody's in charge of it
so that's all narrative so why does
these narratives exist
because different people want different
things for themselves and their future
you know there's a lot of people are
angry with how things are
but also there's something about
bitcoin that most people don't
understand
why did facebook get so big
it's because it used behavioral
economics
which is the like button daniel kahneman
taught all of these guys from
from um google facebook
twitter in fact every major platform was
taught by the
guy who won the nobel prize for
behavioural economics
they explained how the dopamine system
works
and how like buttons and follows and
likes
make us feel rewarded right
you can affect human behavior then
that was in 2007 that he basically held
this
famous summit for all of the leaders of
silicon valley who adopted it
on mass and took over the world then
in 2009 comes bitcoin
bitcoin is the perfect
behavioral network because it rewards
you in money
the more people you bring into the
network the more your money goes up
that by definition will create tribalism
because
everybody is now incentivized for their
network to go up
more than the other network and for all
other networks to fail
it is an incredibly powerful tool for
building a network
where you have money attached to it so
imagine if every facebook like
was a dollar imagine what that would do
or everybody you brought onto facebook
page and facebook shares
that's what bitcoin is it's incredibly
powerful and that's why it creates
narratives
because like a religion it's all about
getting more and more people into it
yeah i mean you touched on two things
there so the tribalism is something i
really want to talk to you about but
i want to go back a sec i can't remember
what the netflix documentary was i
watched the netflix
one about maybe you know the social
media
um uh social network yeah whatever it
was yeah
yeah and wow that blew my mind i mean i
knew already
the programming and this but you know
it's the dopamine it's the like pulling
down and seeing the refresh
getting the hit the notification if you
haven't seen it watch the secrets of
silicon valley a two-part series on the
bbc
that was five years before the netflix
documentary
and it is unbelievable and explains this
in great detail
everything that that is going on here
yeah and like on this documentary they
even have to have um i think there's a
job now about
digital ethics you know if it's
ethically okay
to because they know that they're
programming us they know that they're
doing that
um you know every time every time they
get follow every time they get a
notification it's a dopamine hit so they
know that
they're sort of creating that addiction
so they now have
people in you know actually job
vacancies for
you know people understanding whether
this is ethical or not
well this is a real problem because
once you've unleashed the genie out of
the bottle of behavioral economics and
big data
everybody figures out how to use it for
different means
and it splinters everybody into
different groups
um and it it's almost impossible to deal
with because it's a
network right so it's not centrally
pushed
facebook's not centrally pushed yes
there's an algorithm and stuff like that
but it's a network that everybody's
incentivized to get more people into the
network because it makes them feel good
by getting the dopamine hit of the likes
it's crazy and that's where we are and
bitcoin
is the like the most perfect echelon of
this
of anything i've ever seen and most
people don't really understand that
so you mentioned tribalism so this is
hot right because
you were attacked for wanting to know a
little bit about xrp
um so what did you learn about xrp
um not a lot i mean i just had one
interview but you know what was
interesting as i said i've got an open
mind to it when somebody
whenever in the investing world when
everybody says they hate something
it's usually the time to buy it i
haven't bought xrp
maybe i never will but i reached out to
somebody i really trusted
santiago velez and said look tell me
about it and
he's a super super intelligent very
rational
very balanced person and he sat down
with me for just over an hour
to explain how much of a use case it has
and how it's being used and where it
could go and again he's not saying it's
definitely going there he's not part of
the xrp army
he's just saying listen rel the
narrative is behind the reality
um and then that is it's a scam
because a centralized company issued the
tokens he's like
yeah that's pretty normal most companies
issue shares so
yes it's with the token it's the defined
amount we know how many it is
and this is how it works and then this
is who's using it and this is its value
system and this is how it could
appreciate in value
and i'm like okay i get it this is
you know i know there's still people who
say he doesn't understand
it's a scam it's not it's just a
different thing
and it's not bitcoin nor is ethereum
bitcoin
nor is anything else bitcoin bitcoin is
bitcoin and so
we don't need to compare them it's like
comparing saying well it's not an orange
no it's an apple no it's not an orange
i can't hear it's not an orange no it's
an apple it's different fruit
that's what's going on right now yeah i
i think it's pretty interesting
i think it's kind of um quite
interesting because the bitcoin
community is all about you know
generally speaking freedom um which
kind of implies freedom of everything
right like freedom of speech freedom of
thought
freedom to you know understand more
especially when we look at
bitcoin as views on politics and
everything that's been going on at the
moment whether it be
you know counselling people and so on
there seems to be some kind of common
ground that bitcoin has sort of had when
it comes to this thing
um which is why i'm surprised that we're
not allowed to ask questions like wait
what is xrp you know what what is
ethereum
or could there be a future financial
system where there are many protocols
there's an interoperability layer across
them that allows assets to move
you can have bitcoin that trades on
xrp's
network and on ethereum's network can
that happen
yes will it happen yes will somebody
it's already happening
it's already happening so get used to it
but
to say it can there can only be one
you might say i think there's only going
to be one in the future
so i i want to bet on that i'm fact i'm
so passionate about it i'm going to
short the other ones
that's how the world actually works by
saying
you can't even talk about xrp because
you're an idiot for not seeing what we
see
is religion and i don't think that's
right
but again if you remember its behavioral
incentive structure
is if you can get your network to be the
one
you make all the money then your bags
pump basically
yeah because you take over the world so
therefore
you're incentivized not to play across
networks
but once you start looking at the rest
of the world and understanding okay
this is a whole future financial system
that's all going to net together in this
incredible new way then you're
incentivized to say
well other things may be undervalued
versus bitcoin
some may be overvalued and that's how we
can invest accordingly
to take advantage of the whole space
and again somebody may say oh it's all
going to be built on bitcoin
great then just invest in bitcoin
if you think they're all a scam that's
i've been saying to people a lot of
people say
well ripples are scams xrp's the scams
are fantastic
short it that's how markets deal with
that
you short it and you can make money but
then yeah i mean
no you know i wouldn't do that oh you
can't short a scam on that really
yeah i mean i you know like i said
that's how financial markets work that
that's the that's the free market for
you
you like it you don't like it do your
research you're incentivized to do your
research
um so you know no one's forcing you to
buy xrp
i want to get your thoughts actually on
privacy coins have you looked into them
much
um i mean i know i was yeah go on
tell me about your thoughts on privacy
points um
there will be a place for them and you
know some will get regulated and
some will be used you know i think
there's a place for all of this
you know privacy coins matter
particularly when people are
they really matter when you're in a
jurisdiction that is
oppressive in terms of comes with
violence
adherence with violence well then having
privacy in the extreme is
incredibly valid and i think it will
stay around for that
you know will the us try and shut down
this kind of stuff of course they will
um and we've seen this before i've
talked about this a couple of times
um in the uk back in 2014 something like
that no
earlier
the whole bunch of synthetic
drugs that came onto the market and they
were called plant food at the time
okay i don't recall right it's a
synthetic stimulant right it's a coke
interesting kind of thing yeah it came
out
and obviously they weren't banned so
everyone was importing them from china
it was a fraction of the cost of
drugs and it went viral in the uk
and what was that but what was it what
was it what was the substance
it was a synthetic thing that triggered
the same sensor
sensory system oh and it made it
and so this went viral all across the
world now so what the regulators did was
they tried to ban it by saying this
chemical formula substance is banned
so then the chinese reinvented another
one and then another one and another one
and the regulators had to then figure
some all-encompassing way
but they couldn't get rid of it new
zealand in the end just said fine it's
illegal
we can't regulate it um
see different jurisdictions deal with
stuff like this internet privacy
is the same issue ins you know there's
many issues on the internet
the same china you don't get the choice
the us you get probably more choice than
than you need to have different
countries will and europe will change
will probably be somewhere in the middle
um and it's just how it is
yeah i was talking to um a couple of
people from the monero
core development team and they gave
quite an interesting opinion they were
sort of like well you know we have cash
cash is inherently anonymous um to
obviously some extent
um and the same aml
procedures that are put in place for
cash will be put in place for privacy
points to say you want to go
and buy a house with um a load of monero
the the person you're buying it from
might have several regulatory
you know um and compliance things
whereby you have to sort of give proof
of funds and say
yeah you know and they'll say like they
do with cash so in europe right now
most countries somewhere averaging about
5 000 euros you're allowed to use for a
transaction
so you regulate that and say fine if you
want your your cash money
no problem with that anything over 5000
euros has to be declared
for aml and that's it and that will
happen
now if you don't want to bring in if you
don't want to bring it into your system
i
into your tax system same with cash
nobody has to know about it so all of
spain still operates with cash
you know stuffed under their mattresses
and in bangkok but if you want to bring
into the system
it's bloody hard unless you'll find
somebody else who'll accept cash
so things trade at different prices yeah
absolutely and i kind of see that being
the situation with cryptos right because
i think
that's the hardest thing you can trade
anonymously even with bitcoin
um but as soon as you get to um the
the on-ramps and the off-ramps that's
why you hit the kyc and
other than that there's no way really to
bring into the system unless like you
said you know you're dealing you know i
guess
peer-to-peer literally if you could
offer me a service in bitcoin
yes and the problem is is i'm not sure
whether you can get away with selling
a house for no transaction so it's
it's difficult it's difficult so yeah i
can give you bitcoin and nobody knows
about it
but what can you do with it what can i
get an exchange it's actually it's
it's tricky yeah it is so just
finally where do you see the space then
in 20 years from now i know it's
impossible to
kind of see but and the financial system
in general
where do you see it all i i think we're
headed towards the internet of money
by a very broad definition which is
digital assets have
value and digital assets are
transferable exchangeable recordable
all of those things and many most
physical assets
will be digitized in terms of its value
capture and transfer of value
whether it's the art market or or you
know
thing the trusted ownership of
everything will be on blockchain
technologies which ones
who knows um but that's definitely
coming
you know the tokenization of all assets
and income streams and revenue streams
and intellectual property rights and
everything is coming and it it's all
coming
um so you know
it change it it's gonna change
our world as much as the internet
changed our world yeah i
totally think so and actually i do have
one last question for you um
because you mentioned it earlier cbdc's
what do you think is going to go on
there because i have this kind of idea
in my head
um just maybe i've watched too many
films i don't know but i have this idea
whereby
i feel like we're gonna have a kind of
like tug of war between
because like you said everything is
inevitable it's gonna go digital i
always say this everything is digital
from
you know dating shopping whatever it is
it's all digital socializing so working
um so i feel like there's gonna be like
this tug of war between
you know government um you know their
own cryptocurrency cbdc's
and then the crypto community who are
pushing that narrative that we spoke
about earlier
i think they all coexist i don't think
rid of bitcoin
i think it ends up being the reserve
asset that has a lot of value to a lot
of people some governments will adopt it
some will try and regulate against it i
just think it's going to be there like
gold it's always been there
people have tried to ban it from time to
time never really work so
i don't have a i don't think they have
an issue with it either
the central bank digital currencies are
a whole different thing
um what that is is at the top level yeah
it's much easier for me to send you
money right one second thing
great it means that stuff like bitcoin
becomes seamless into this so for
taxation capturing and all of this stuff
that makes nation states making nation
states
fine it's gonna completely change
how economics works because
monetary policy run by central banks
fiscal policy run by governments
that all blends into one because this is
the rise again
of behavioral economics and big data
sets because i can incentivize you
differently
to me you can have a different rate of
interest you can
we can do down to the individual in
terms of stimulus or
penalty reward systems but obviously
governments can use it for nefarious
means too so if they
catch you driving you know five miles an
hour over the speed limit they'll just
take it straight from your wallet
because
oh that's scary that brings me out yeah
um and that and that's the problem
um but it's incredibly powerful in a
recession like this
to have gone okay hairdressing salons
right here's that here's you know
here's 10 grand in your account
immediately um
and we'll monitor your wallet and if
you're running out of cash
we'll redo that for stimulus that would
have really helped
yes as opposed to giving it to a bunch
of banks
via quantitative easing and assuming
they're going to do the right thing
which they won't because they'll either
hoard it
or give it to their best customers so
the people who actually need it can't
get it
you know this again
matters not whether you like it or not
it's coming
it's happening it's freaky programmable
money at central bank level
is definitely going to happen well there
you go i was going to ask you your last
thoughts but i think that's it isn't it
programmable money
on a central bank level is going to
happen yeah there you go please get the
heads around that
well i want to thank you so much it's
been such a pleasure um
and thank you so much for coming on yeah
really enjoyed it
all right guys don't forget to tune in
next thursday we will be live
at 12 p.m est we'll see you then